[Music]
this is about all new community people
that just want to live their life in a
normal way and once you put any type of
obstacle there these into the penalty
had to go on later that all I think only
in recent times it's kind of come to the
fore that you actually drive across the
border and people simply don't
understand that we the long history of
you know crossing the border so we just
want to treat it the way we've always
feel I'm just think you know that common
sense for real we have gotten sure that
we do this property otherwise a
generation is going to be affected
whatever happens with brexit does not
provide an urgency for the use of
violence
[Music]
it's a virtually invisible line but this
is the place where plans for a speedy
brexit came to a shuddering halt welcome
to the Northern Irish border we're a
long way from Westminster but the
turmoil there is largely about what
happens here after the UK leaves the EU
if there is an abundance of solutions as
some suggest why is Briggs it's still
waiting at a non-existent checkpoint
some wanted to remain British others
wanted an independent Ireland so the
British government drew a line in the
sand
creating Northern Ireland their soldiers
maintained partition blowing up border
roads to make them impossible there's a
fella - Lannon bull shades of the border
here and he practically could not get
from one farm to another John Moyna who
lives in the South couldn't even cross
the bridge to chat to his neighbors in
the north in the past this road was dug
up or blown up from here right back up
to the red back up to the the house you
see there just across the top of that
hill that was known as Flynn this is
known as Flynn's crossing and that road
was created to a point where you
wouldn't know anything existed the IRA
breached the border on a regular basis
many died defending it
and they absorbed the violence on behalf
of the rest of Northern Ireland they
were the last stand in County Fermanagh
alone 116 people were murdered among
them three brothers one particular found
in this area pay an extremely high price
it's the only kiss over the years of the
troubles were three brothers were
murdered one by one the IRA declared war
on the Greens that they would wipe the
might in the 1980 year 1981 and so
rolling was murdered on the 5th of June
sessile was shot on the 9th of November
but then died on 11th of November on
Remembrance Day I mean four years later
Jimmy Graham was murdered on the 1st of
February 1985 having survived two
assassination attempts in 1981
so they've had a huge price it wasn't
always about the politics of partition
farmers just needed to get from A to B
by the shortest route in some places
they reopened the roads themselves
people call them the border Busters
people took on themselves to make the
changes or I can remember one particular
practice in the south of us on the armed
the army came out with rubber bullets
fired the CS gas fired was complete
pandemonium honestly miracle that nobody
was killed her horse hoarded but that
didn't deter people people kept common
and and kept attempting to open these
roads it is worn with pride at Dublin's
Croke Park but the Gaelic football kit
is a cross-border production
[Applause]
with factories on both sides involved in
the manufacture players won't want to
say their colors intercepted at the
border
Oh needles is a national institution the
largest manufacturer of sportswear on
this island it supplies jerseys for
football and hurling teams and legions
of supporters but every piece of kit
packed up for distribution from its
factory extra ban in County Tyrone will
already have crossed the border multiple
times
from Dublin port the yarn threads its
way north to be woven into fabric the
fabric crosses the border for a second
time to be dyed in Dublin for a third
time to be cut in Northern Ireland for a
fourth time to be stitched in Dublin for
a fifth time to be packaged in Northern
Ireland and for a sixth time to be
distributed from Dublin some kits
crossed the border for a seventh or even
its time before reaching their
destination
fearing the possibility of a hard border
this company has already made provision
for the relocation of its Northern
Ireland factory to County Donegal the
managing director says politicians need
to consider the many people he employs
here com2 you're pissed extra bond see
them packed a new deal brexit would have
look at the staff here that are
depending the 700 stops the bond could
come from all traditions and see how it
would affect their labor hood do they
want to be associated with you know
lossing jobs for the sake of the union
or whatever you know we just want to
treat it the way we've always treated
and just think you know let common sense
for real
there are multiple crossing points on
what will be the only land border
between the UK and EU to avoid
checkpoints to resume agreed to a
backstop position Northern Ireland would
remain in the EU customs union and
single market if necessary when
unionists said no Boris Johnson proposed
to compromise Northern Ireland would
leave the customs union but accept
single market regulations when the EU
said no hopes of a deal faded until the
prime minister met his Irish counterpart
and announced that they could see a
pathway to agreement with the border
centre stage for so long we assembled a
panel of experts to try to understand
why it's proven so difficult to break
the deadlock so what's the solution it
should be some leadership in politics we
put forward actual solutions that really
require a lot more technical work from
the experts so for example we put
forward about a year and a half ago the
enhanced economic zone where trade can
flow through Northern Ireland into GB
and from Europe and from GB into Europe
via Northern Ireland any alternative
arrangements need to do what the
backstop does and it's very very simple
for us what we need not just to thrive
but to survive brags it is to have
unfettered access to both the grip
British market and the EU market some
people are saying that it's an either/or
for us in Northern Ireland it's not we
would concur without we think we need
trade east west as well as north so f
food flows on to the UK market tariff
free and we face tariffs gunite we are
in a Haydn tune awesome
our farmers will disappear and remember
there's nothing more important than the
food we eat and takes farmers to produce
food journalist do you believe that we
are still capable of reaching a solution
that meets the objectives of the Baxter
I think we should be whether there's a
willingness to do it or not as the other
matter the understanding of what goes on
here is very very limited
and people don't have an understanding
of it I think only in recent times it's
kind of come to the fore that you
actually drive across the border and
people simply don't understand that
surely in the year 2019 when your mobile
phone contract whatever you are in the
world there has got to be a
technological solution we haven't seen
anywhere in the world with the sort of
technology that has been talked about it
actually works even if you look at some
of the smartest borders in the world and
one of the best is of course the Norway
Sweden border they have average delays
there of about nine and a half minutes
they have 1,300 commercial vehicles
crossing those points at there we have
13,500 yet thousand five hundred just on
one crossing
the technology is fine but are you going
to chip every car are you going to chip
every human you know if a visitor lines
from North America I don't necessarily
want to have to chip and pin them when
they arrive maybe we need to lock these
people in a room and tell them they're
not getting right until they have a
solution and that's not just a solution
around three it but that is the solution
going forward so we have a good
relationship within the EU we have got
to ensure that we do this properly
otherwise as has been said a generation
is going to be affected
at Queen's University Belfast they've
been researching the border for decades
dr. Katie Hayward says people in Great
Britain don't always recognize its
significance it's so different here even
in the next generation even in those who
actually didn't live through the
troubles they still in living with the
legacy of conflict and if you talk about
a hard border they repeat things that
they heard from their family about what
it meant and the trauma involved in the
CS Lewis reading room she explained why
many people in Northern Ireland regarded
talk of an easy solution to this problem
as fantasy in one way and the Good
Friday Agreement did not solve the
conflict in Northern Ireland in many
ways it took the border and made it in
some ways more significant because it
said basically the key identity is in
Northern Ireland two communities differ
fundamentally about the border and that
explains another fear violence border
checkpoints could become a target for
dissident republicans but a border in
the save between here and Great Britain
could inflame loyalist tensions border
communities have no desire to return to
the past this needs to be said once and
for all that whatever happens with
brexit it does not provide legitimacy
for the use of violence this is a
political issue which must be resolved
we hear from the Republic of Ireland we
hear from the UK we hear from Europe
they don't want a hard border there
isn't enough mains between those three
parties till actually reach an
accommodation course there is but there
needs to be a compromise and a
willingness to do the deal this is but
ordinary community people that just want
to live their life in a normal way and
once you put any type of obstacle there
these things have a tendency to go on a
life of their own and it would decimate
their those cattle in Northern Ireland
the capital up and I feel up there are
in the South the practicalities of all
this ho how do you actually come up with
a solution but these two things that
walks aid besaid it does sameer to test
me at communities
it's the subtle nature of this border
that lets people identify as British or
Irish or both that was a key component
of the Good Friday Agreement any change
at this frontier even for practical
purposes risks unsettling one community
or the other this has never just been
about cross-border trade important
though that is it's about the delicate
balance the historic compromise that
brought this island peace
[Music]